Children First strengthening the child
guarantee 2 years on from its adoption
and the report by Mrs Sandra Pereira
reducing inequalities and promoting
social inclusion in times of Crisis for
children and their
families colleagues
please if you are leaving the chamber
please do so quietly so we can continue
the discussion here thank you very much
and I would like now to give the floor
to
rapporter Madame Pereira the floor is
yours
please thank you very
much uh I don't have a great deal of
time but I'll do what I can uh child
poverty has a number of Dimensions to it
it's derived from Poverty of the family
so we need a multi-dimensional
response which of course um will go
through increased job
security and an increase in wages as
well as better public
services for children to enjoy their
rights then their parents must
too we can't talk about uh rights of the
child without talking about uh wage
stability for parents uh particularly
putting an end to precariousness and uh
deregulation of hours uh as well as low
wages and uh wage
discrimination as well as other
transports linked to accommodation and
transport as well as an increase in
expenditure on health and
education this of course is affected by
parents income as well
colleagues we need to have uh structural
State policies which adopts a holistic
approach to uh childhood ensuring that
they have the tools and resources that
they
need so that families can see the
responses that they need the resolution
that we're voting on tomorrow will put
forward a series of measures that should
be implemented in member states because
that's the way that we will actually
have an impact on fighting poverty so we
need more investment in public
services in education in health care a
public Universal high quality services
to uh meet fam's needs and the needs of
children in all of their
diversity uh also um to ensure that we
have high quality after school and
preschool
services rights for children and their
parents have to be um implemented
through the an evaluation of the
Practical instruments that will fight
discrimination and violence against
children we have to have targeted
structured
measures the um early years of life have
a key impact on integrated development
for
children uh in their first years
children developed their key
capacities we need to have proper Child
Care uh nurseries and support for
children for families sorry to ensure uh
holistic approach from the very earliest
age we should ensure uh free access to
uh nursery
care
and high quality education to ensure um
the best uh type of uh instruction for
all children regardless of the family
that they come
from to ensure that they enjoy their
full rights to education as set out in
uh constitutions of countries such as my
own we also need free access to care uh
before school for all children up to the
age of 13 to ensure a an approach um
that is focused on the needs of the
individual today is the International
Day on the rights of the child and I
would like to take this opportunity to
talk about those who are in
war um thousands of Palestinian children
have been killed by Israeli forces in
recent weeks uh more than the the entire
number of children killed since 2019 in
other
conflicts one child would be too many
and so we have to see an end to this
children have the right to live in peace
we have to uh put an end to this and to
establish peace based relations between
All
Peoples now to give the floor on behalf
of the commission to the vice president
Madame SCH the floor is yours
please thank thank you chair honorable
members exactly 34 years ago on November
1989 the United Nations adopted the
convention on the rights of the child it
is in commemoration of that Milestone
event that we celebrate World children's
day today it is a reminder that
children's rights are human rights under
any circumstances and everywhere the
four guiding principles of the United
Nations convention on the rights of the
the child uh non-discrimination the best
interest of the child the right to
survival and development and the right
to be
heard they are also reflected in the
European Union chart Charter for of
fundamental rights it is important to
recall them every day like today the
theme for World Children's Day 2023 is
for every child every right for every
child peace for every child a livable
planet for every child a voice yet on
this world Children's Day the European
Union is particularly concerned for the
well-being of children living in
situations of armed conflict Force
displacement and protracted humanitarian
crisis unfortunately our television
screens and social media
fits uh full of the daily Horrors
inflicted upon children around the world
beat in from Gaza to Illegal child
deportations from Ukraine terrorist
attacks in Israel and and armed
conflicts from the Sahel region to Yemen
and Myanmar children do not start
conflicts they deserve and need peace we
as adults as caretakers as policy makers
we have an obligation to protect and
promote All rights of all children and
to ensure that they can live in dignity
this is also the commission's
understanding and our approach to the
rights of the child as we laid it down
in European strategy on the rights of
the child and the European children
child guarantee while the European Union
is one of the most equal and prosperous
regions in the world we have not yet
fully eradicated poverty child poverty
in Europe is not acceptable currently
every fourth child lives at risk of
poverty or social exclusion this
requires decisive actions at all levels
this is what the report on reducing
inequalities and promoting social
inclusions in times of Crisis for
children and their families call free
and we can all agree children growing in
poverty are less likely to do well in
school they are less likely to enjoy
good health they are less likely to
realize their are full potential later
in life this Parliament has been at the
Forefront of the European Union policy
actions to support the most vulnerable
children we highly appreciate that the
proposed children first resolution pays
attention to the quality of the national
action plans adequate financing
stakeholders involvement and proper
governance and monitoring all these
aspects are key also from our point of
view I want to thank my dear colleague
commissioner Nicolas Schmidt for all
this work eight years ago the European
Parliament adopted a resolution on
reducing inequalities with a special
focus on child poverty calling for a
child guarantee today the CH guarantee
is a reality we welcome the fact that 20
European Union member states have set
National Targets on child poverty
reduction we see that in 2022 the number
of children at risk of poverty or social
exclusion decreased in 19 member states
we see 1, 9100 fewer children affected
by poverty in Italy 86,000 fewer
children affected by poverty in gree
while we welcome these figures we remain
concerned that this significant progress
is offset by increases in eight other
member states but we must not be
complacent the commission is tirelessly
working with member states to ensure
that progress is being made and we are
happy with a constructive approach by
the national coordinators a number of
concrete actions have been taken for
example School meals have been
introduced in Croatia and in Luxembourg
in Bulgaria future for Children Health
prevention program will support
approximately 14,000 families honorable
members you have called for better
monitoring we are now working jointly
with the social protection committee to
establish a common monitoring framework
the results should be available in a
matter of few weeks results from their
programming show that combating child
poverty has been defined as a specific
objective in programs of 23 member
states totaling 6.1 billion of European
financing or 8 8.9 billion if National
contributions are added next march will
be another opportunity to to take stock
European member states should report on
their progress in implementing child
guarantee here we must draw attention to
the fact that primary responsibility for
implementation of the child guarantee
lies with member states we recall that
an investment in children is a tangible
investment in their societies and their
economies we must preserve this
stability as we all know how fragile it
is sustainable investment in children
will be key I thank you and I look
forward for this
debate thank you very much Madame
commissioner now on behalf of the
committee on women's rights and gender
equality vice president of the European
Parliament Madame kopach
please
P president ladies and gentlemen uh the
parliament deals with many topics
related to children's rights on a daily
basis like uh the European chat
guarantee we're discussing today but
looking at today's world we have to say
clearly that this is still not enough we
have armed conflicts poverty climate
change violence against children both in
the real world and online we have lack
of access to education and health care
to psychological and social support so
much needed in the crisis of recent
years this all shapes and influences the
next Generations meaning that it also
determines our
future I want to stress with the out
utmost uh importance children in Ukraine
children in Gaza and in Israel in Sudan
and everywhere where adults wage their
Wars they have the same rights to live
to live in order to grow up and develop
with a sense of security love and
respect this right is universal
inalienable and does not depend on in
which country and which side of the wall
the child was born at the end I should
say something obvious all children are
our children and the deserve the best
and we here in the parliament uh treat
should treat it as obvious and should be
a good example to others thank you very
much thank you very much on behalf of
the group of the European People's Party
colleague Mr ging the floor is yours
yeah feel thank you very much Madame
President welcome
commissioner 20th of November
International Day of the rights of the
child here we are in Parliament and we
having a debate here we've had a
wonderful report but there you go that's
the International Day of rights of the
child that's how we deal with our
children to be honest I think we should
be ashamed of
this it should be a full house here full
full chamber there should be people here
to show dignity to world day and rights
of the child this children's day is here
to strengthen and bolster rights of the
child looking at children poverty to
deal with child labor address that not
just to slap ourselves on the back I
mean these are important discussions and
and have them just shuffled away in a
document a report I think it's a
shame I'm uh from the family party in in
Germany I'm the chair of the party we
have a lot of input into this report I
think we want to have additional child
guarantee we need to have additional
money for um child benefit and parental
money as well that will
help children in their families so that
families as well can
plan and I come from a small party but
this is absolutely essential in this
European Parliament and we hope that
next year after the European elections
here on the 20th of November we will
have a full CH chamber and we'll have a
a discrete item on the agenda for this
world day of the rights of the child
because the children of the world
children of Europe have deserve this
they are the future they're this
terrible word human capital they are the
people who we need to promote who we
need to look after and we shouldn't
allow these people to be pushed further
and further into poverty we shouldn't
allow child labor in Europe and together
with Miss Pereira as she said we need
to look at what's happening to war wars
and poverty and economic misery so this
is something that we need to be active
about to help the children of
Europe and what we draw lessons from
this year should be put into what we do
next year thank you of the group of the
progressive Alliance of socialists and
Democrats in the European Parliament
colle Mr Ben
please today is the international day of
the child and it pains me to have to
repeat that the situation for children
is still tragic when we look at uh child
poverty in Europe and in Italy looking
at my own
country Georgia
Malone um received um the national plan
on the childhood guarantee from the EU
and it's an excellent plan but nothing's
happening with it we don't know what's
happened to it uh the working group on
the rights of the child has um uh looked
at a disastrous budgetary law the
um PNR has looked at um the rights of
children we know that um in 2022 there
are a number of children in absolute
poverty absolute poverty we're talking
about uh there's only um 38% of primary
school children that are guaranteed
fulltime um this is the highest figure
for uh the worst figure for the European
Union these figures should make us angry
and should the fact that we've wasted
time um this is shameful and of course
this isn't only true just for Italy but
childhood poverty is increasing across
Europe there are millions at risk we
can't allow the years that we fought
against um child poverty to be
lost tomorrow for example we can work
together to move forward we want to see
at least 20 billion in funding for the
childhood guarantee to provide
additional support for these programs
and we hope that uh this will be done in
a correct time frame also um support in
uh Refugee children and Ukrainian
children and children from
elsewhere otherwise if we don't move
what we'll be doing is condeming uh
millions of children to a desperate
future R Europe group colleague Mr piso
please thank you very much dear chair
dear vice president sha dear colleagues
a child living in poverty is a
catastrophe clearly for their family but
for the society at large and today we
are talking about how the EU is taking
care of our children are we taking care
of our children well in Europe
respecting their rights and providing
access and
opportunities and the answer is
no today's debate is not a theoretical
exercise about world's problems we have
5 million children in poverty in the EU
today today we are debating a resolution
prepared by the employment and social
Affairs Committee of this Parliament led
by in Europe but supported by all
political groups and develop in a full
consultation and transparency with the
stakeholders and indeed it's a
resolution to try to redress this
unacceptable situation the European
child guarantee is the wild card to get
millions of children out of
poverty and we need that because this
can be a game
Cher ambition and proper implementation
through the national action plans we
need to set crazy ambitious actions by
constantly being more coordinating
better governance having an European
Authority for children having the
additional budget that we need of 20
billion and plus having meaningful
implementation and Synergy among
authorities children and inequality
poverty social exclusion these are words
that should never stay to each other we
should do everything in our power to
provide the children a best future a
better future to learn and become
amazing human beings that they are
destined to be away from poverty social
exclusion and inequality thank you very
much thank you very much now in behalf
of the group of the greens European free
Alliance colleague Mrs damato
please thank you commissioner the plan
to implement the child guarantee
published this spring shows in black and
white the serious situation Italy is
facing as well as Europe of course when
it comes to child poverty and social
exclusion and the numbers of shocking
34% of miners in the south of the
country do not have access to the
so-called key rights lack of affordable
Nursery places among the highest levels
of early School leaving in Europe
psychological distress Ram Shuckle
classrooms lack of canteen
access poor housing conditions and a
lack of access to high quality medical
treatment are the tragic reality for an
increasing number of Miners and their
families who are at the same time facing
an Ever higher um living cost
cuts to he Healthcare and schools as
well as the delayed implementation of
the National Recovery and resilience
plan are political choices that are
creating a real social crisis and what's
Malone's right doing well they're
obsessed with the birth rate and with
the babies to come perhaps they'd be
better focusing on the children who are
already here and who are simply asking
for a dignified
life thank you very much now in behalf
of the European conservatives and
reformist group senor sakar
president commissioner
colleagues we are all part of a family
we're given life natural bonds and Care
a people who grow up in a stable loving
family start out at a huge advantage and
we want every child to enjoy this Good
Fortune uh people who have experienced
Selfless Love within a family um
understand their dignity as a person and
this is how they they build relations
with others and they can give it back to
society as well the family is the best
tool for social inclusion and to fight
against poverty and inequalities its
need to um value the family and to
ensure that that it's the heart of
social policy particularly at times of
Crisis and yet this chamber is working
to replace it uh this is leading to
mistrust uh pitching family members
against one another and distancing
children from their
parents
it's claiming that it can put an end to
Poverty by putting an end to
life and yet life is uh the most
important thing to protect the best
guarantee for children are their
families we have to help parents to do
their work properly thank you graas
thank you very much next speaker on
behalf of identity and democracy group
Madame thank you madam president
president Madam commissioner the current
situation in the European Union should
encourage you to adopt a an attitude of
being
more uh show a greater degree of
humility because we can see that the
situation for children in the EU is
thanks to political choices in the EU
children's rights are not being
respected they're being affected by
poverty but who is it who's imposed
austerity measures for many many years
who was uh pointing the finger at
countries for not paying more money for
these this people uh in the population
and we're seeing that the European Union
isn't doing what they should do they're
going beyond what is decent in fact
they're meant to be a great social
protector and have conscience of the
dramatic situation that we're seeing
experienced by our populations
especially our children what's the you
proposing well all sorts of Pious wishes
Without
End Of course everybody should have the
right to security to education to a
healthy environment in which they can ER
grow up and and Blossom but we're seeing
contradictory me messages between
financing everything and nothing to
prioritizing all other subjects instead
and taking away from the member states
their freedom to act in a sovereign M um
manner according to their needs
and bolstering the right to look at the
value of dignity of work you're going to
condemn children to live in a world
that's not going to protect them anymore
so what we need to do is stop pointing
the finger and make and give people
lessons and act instead next speaker
colleague Mrs yoka please the floor is
yours thank you
thank you
and for many years now there has been a
crisis in our country and in other
member states previously we were one of
the best performing member states when
it came to child
poverty thus far however 83% of Roma
children in Europe live in poverty
when the strategy was first
announced we
were very hopeful and we heard the
Spanish presidency and all of its uh
priorities which again presented hope we
talked about enforced um controls better
monitoring differences with across
sector uh
management
but with everything we've seen at the
moment with war um
inflation these families have been hard-
hit
again so we need change we need to
guarantee housing we need to offer
Nursery
places and we need to ensure access to
education the floor is yours
please
[Music]
thank you president
commissioner it is uh World children's
day today today is just a
reminder um that the Earth does not
belong to us uh we have to give it back
and we have to give it to our children
the children are our future and they
deserve a lot more than what we are
offering them at the moment children
should not be victims of war children
should not be dying uh by being shot or
because of
bombs children shouldn't be going to
work and they shouldn't be victims of
abuse they should be able to go to
school play Dream and enjoy their
childhood uh children are our world and
our world is better because it is full
of children saving uh just one child
will contribute to keeping up hope thank
you colleague Mr bras the floor is
yours thank you very much
president all children all rights that's
the slogan of this year's commemorations
of world children's day and this seems
to be far from the reality in face of
numerous conflicts and crises in Europe
and its neighborhood we cannot ignore
the Russian aggression in Ukraine the
suffering of children the escalation of
violence in Israel and Palestine
especially in Gaza crisis and conflicts
affect children directly not just
because of the quality of their
childhoods affected but also their
possibilities to realize their potential
and that's why our votes are worth more
than our word sometimes we have two
resolutions on the table we'd like to
reiterate the urgent call for at least
20 billion additional Euros by
2027 for the European child guarantee
and we have to make sure that member
states don't tighten their belts even
further in the
future uh to the detriment of vulnerable
groups such as children in these sort of
times when people are suffering we have
to make sure that we can strengthen the
resilience of children and their
families by investing in quality Public
Services accessible to all have
allowances for children and families and
make sure that work life balance bance
can be struck we have to have adequate
minimum wages guaranteed adequate
minimum income for a decent life for all
children even in the event that parents
or Guardians may lose their
jobs children are not represented
directly by the European Parliament so
we have an even greater responsibility
to be the voice of all those children
and to act in their best interest thank
you speaker colleague
Mrs
we are one of the
richest regions of the
world
and in
particular
we uh need to look at protecting
children particularly those from Roma
Community they often live in areas um
without Health Care without drinking
water and we also see segregation of of
uh Roma children into special schools
that's why our
delegation has carried out um a European
Parliament mission to uh communities of
uh Roma people in Slovakia and we want
to ask the commission how is this
possible um do we need more data and
statistics well that's uh very easy it's
very easy to make speeches but what we
have to do do is to defend children's
rights that's the duty of the European
Union it's our duty to invest in
children we can't uh give into populist
discourse particularly when it comes to
education we need proper scrutiny and
monitoring uh with a proper uh data and
statistics there are uh five million
children and we have to ensure that we
can improve their lives in the
EU the um European convention on the
rights of the child was unan unanimously
um adopted in
1997 the rights of um the child are
inali they have the right to uh not be
victims of war that's for that reason
that we need an immediate ceasefire the
right to food the right to housing these
are inable rights for children as well
but we still have thousands of Children
at Risk of poverty in
Europe This guarantee needs to become
effective in all of our member
states it's high time that um cop 28 uh
finally becomes the first cop where we
see children involved as well because
the right to participation is theirs
too we should fight uh child labor this
is something that we um said very
clearly in 2019 and this fight is still
on we also need to ensure that um the
rights of families and All Families um
lgbtq families included are um protected
as well thank
you now next speaker colleague Mrs
mazure the floor is
yours
chair commissioner ladies and gentlemen
in accordance with the provisions in the
convention on children's rights in our
actions concerning children we must
always work um to guarantee children's
uh benefit in Poland in recent years the
social policy was the area where we had
the most dynamic changes and family
became the heart of State
policy you cannot talk about a child
without the child's Family Modern and
independent states must be based on good
sound foundations and a family is such a
foundation in recent years my country
has shown that investment into families
are not costs but the best investment
programs such as 500 plus which in a
significant way reduce the poverty among
children Good Start uh family uh Capital
became the basis to guarantee security
for children our children are future and
only by supporting families we can
guarantee their stability children must
be protected with every respect during
war and in peace times and in particular
during war in families in various
institutions we adults should care for
the uh safety security and good
development of children it's good to
talk about it but we must act uh fast
thanks
please thank you president
colleagues
Commissioners two years um since the uh
child guarantee um was launched we um
have first now looked at um how we're
doing on the program and looking at
making correction uh correcting measures
already we're trying to streamline
everything produce better controls and
ensure transparency of
funds
it's always the way that uh some things
work better than others and it's for
that reason that uh now we have to look
at um ensuring that um the child
guarantee has uh sufficient funds
running to 2027 and its own budgetary
line we need to fully understand also
where the guarantee is working and um in
need to help their member states to uh
identify any
irregularities we need to monitor the
guarantee and ensure cooperation between
the member
states now when requesting if we're
requesting another agency or another
superstructure that's something we would
not be um for instead we believe that
these funds should go straight to
children and straight to the child
guarantee we therefore believe that the
management and control of the guarantee
should be done within existing
structures the child guarantee remains
in um All European member states and
we've got National plans which have been
approved which should now be implemented
thank you very much next speaker Mr
furor the floor is yours please
gra thank you president uh the five star
movement supports the resolution on
strengthening the guarantee system for
vulnerable
children this is a topic that's
important to us and I do want to draw
Europe's attention to one particular
issue of 207 Italian families that are
waiting to adopt belarussian children
these are orphans who live in
institutions but are regularly hosted by
Italian families in um the um stays that
are organized since Chernobyl disaster
these have created um indisoluble links
and have pushed many families to try to
adopt the children but because of um
bureautic procedures since 2020 there's
been an end to this without a letter of
guarantee on the well-being of the
children these um children cannot
Embrace their new families I hope that
the commission will act to um open up
the situation
because um we Cann allow administrative
reasons to put an ended children's
happiness thank youa the is
pleas thank you president
commissioner every part session we hear
about the various crisis buff buffeting
Europe and the impact they have on all
our
citizens governments have done their
best to help people protect themselves
but one group group in particular is
unable to do so which is precisely why
children are considered vulnerable
because they are unable to do anything
to improve their situation because they
depend on others and because poverty is
their inheritance and we know that they
will continue to suffer from the effects
of poverty even when they grow up this
is not Justice today as we celebrate
International Day on the rights of the
child we need to bear in mind that
nearly a quarter of all children alive
are at risk of poverty and this
notwithstanding the fact that Europe is
a continent built on the Bedrock of
values such as in equality and dignity
this means that everyone should have an
opportunity to enjoy a better life
irrespective of who they are or where
they hail from two years ago Europe
armed itself with the child guarantee
because we know that it is unjust for
children to live in poverty I believe
that we will never have a fair Society
for as long as there are children going
hungry with little or no access to
education and Health Care much has been
done to help children much more remains
to be done and this resolution is a step
in the right direction we have a child
guarantee but we want it to work better
and if we wish our children to have a
bright and promising future we need to
protect their life and health the floor
is yours
please thank you president Madame vice
president the Netherlands unfortunately
is no different to the rest of Europe in
our country as well there are parents
with children who get
uh who are 500 EUR a month too short
that's not on anymore children who grow
up in poverty feel the consequences
during the course of the rest of their
life both in school on the labor market
but also on their
health and for those missed
opportunities it's not just they who
have to pay for that but we all pay for
that as well because one any single
child growing up in poverty uh is one
too many on Wednesday we have general
election we can't have just empty
promises from new the new government we
need specific actions raise the minimum
wage and increase in parents income
invest in school lunches for children
and education that's the only way we can
deal with child poverty thank you thank
you very much next
speaker Madame
President commissioner
colleagues the children are our
future we have to uh take the
opportunity of this International World
children's day um to send out a powerful
message of unity the covid-19 pandemic
deprived children of education and uh
key social contact UM to help them
develop poverty and
precariousness are still depriving too
many children in Europe of opportunities
we need clear political responses based
on inclusion for all we must plan for
long-term investment in quality services
for early
years that includes uh properly trained
staff who can meet the needs and uh
periods of
childhood we can't forget the most
vulnerable um the roll out of the
European uh childood guarantee has to
ensure that all are guaranteed access to
school decent housing health care and
healthy
food our goal can't just be to reduce
inequality but to prevent it from
arising in the first place that's our
shared responsibility we must Forge a
future where each and every child can
flourish and achieve their
dreams thank you very much next speaker
Mr rle the floor is
yours Madame President colleagues today
is the uh International Day on the
rights of the child and I would like to
focus on a topic which is particularly
important to me and that's child
poverty it's so important to me because
I was affected by it as well I know what
it means to not have any money to go to
the cinema or go swimming I know what
it's like to be mocked because you can't
afford the right
clothes we um have got
um one of the highest levels of um child
poverty in um Germany we're um at um
we're 20th in the ranking in
Germany so
20th Germany so here we're talking about
2.2 million children and that's why I'm
talking about this today because of
those um nine of those 2.2 million 9
133,000 of those children came to us as
migrants out of 2.2
m933 th000 and so we have to be honest
when we're talking about child poverty
we're also talking about
migration last week um we celebrated St
Martin's
Day St Martin shared his coat his
cloak those who want to fight child
poverty needs to save the social State
and if we want to do that then we need
to end illegal
migration thank you next speaker Mr
Nicola alanos floor is
yours thank
you 5,500 children uh have been killed
in Gaza there are clinics hospitals
maternity units that are being
bombed and the European Union is making
declarations that
support uh the
uh con the um conqueror uh this is
hypocrisy we have want to see an end to
these bombs because those children are
our
children uh people ask why don't have uh
poor children have access to hot meals
or to school or Health
Care well this explains uh why there
isn't any support from uh states to poor
families this is uh where European
policy ends up when we talk about uh
effective protection for children we
need other policies to go hand inhand
with that we need
to
strengthen and provide support for those
movements that are fighting for those
rights rights to uh school to food
and uh for the state to ensure that all
children can go to school and eat
without the private sector getting
involved man Madame President the EU has
been tested harshly over the recent
years energy crisis covid uh a war which
is against
the international law and children are
the ones who affect most they're the
ones who are the most vulnerable they
health and their schooling is affected
their all sorts of aspects of their
lives are affected all sorts of people
around the EU can't pay their bills they
don't they can't afford food for their
children one of four children are at
risk of social exclusion or poverty one
in four in the EU growing up in poverty
has a negative effect on the rights of
the child here and now but also later on
in their lives and the child
guarantee is hence a very important tool
that we must deliver on if the EU can't
ensure a safe and
secure uh time for children to grow up
in it will affect both our children and
our future as well thank you thank you
very much next speaker colleague
Mrs
please thank you president
colleagues children don't choose their
families that's why it is up to us as
politicians to help every child to get
the same rights whether they live in
Slovakia or
France whether they live in a palace or
a little
flat there are a lot of children
nowadays that are living in
poverty now happily children don't die
of hunger in Europe anymore but it does
have an impact and we see this in many
families they're not eating a proper
diet uh fruit and vegetables
particularly are very
expensive children can't choose their
schools either and often that is
determined by the resources that a
family
has and then after school activities to
help them develop skills and um grow in
their talents again there are many
children who can't go to those
activities so we have to ensure that
every child has the opportunity to
become an astronaut an engineer or a
doctor Mr Al
please thank you very much president
today is World children's
day
but uh there's been a limited uh impact
of the work that's been done um there
are a huge number of uh children who
experience uh poverty and
precariousness UNICEF has uh set out the
multi-dimensional reasons for poverty um
lack of access to uh clean water uh not
not receiving a proper meal uh War we've
never seen uh so many as there are at
the moment uh the figures are
particularly alarming over 5,000
children have been killed in
Gaza a large
number of children have
disappeared we have to ensure that
international law is respected and that
indiscriminate attacks on children are
stopped all children in the world should
have access to education child labor
should be
stopped it's not child poverty it's poor
families who can't guarantee a proper a
dignified life for all children I have
six speakers on my uh kdi list and I
will start with
Madame the floor is yours
please thank you madam chair dear
colleagues some 34 years ago on this
day or uh also uh more or less at the
same time when students rose up against
against the Communist Regime in
Czechoslovakia the convention on the
rights of the child was uh signed i'
would like to mention the first two
Provisions which say that children
deserve special care and attention and
the second says that family is the best
environment for
children and that family needs
supporting social policy should help uh
parents um do and play their
role and the current debate takes place
at a time when thousands of children
suffer from the
violence of uh committed by Hamas
against Israel I see this conflict
through the child Through The Eyes of
these children and I wish that as soon
as possible the hostages are released
and the conflict
ended I also see today's debate Through
The Eyes of deported Ukrainian children
children whose lives were taken away by
Putin thank you very much next speaker
colleague Mrs graine
please thank you president commissioner
dear colleagues 34 years have passed
since this International Day on the
rights of the child was declared what is
our situation we have 5 million children
in poverty and I'm not talking about
crises about the pandemic about war I'm
talking about the fact that in these 34
years actually the crisis regarding the
rights of the child has deepened I'm not
just talking about colleague children
who maybe um don't have enough heat
don't have enough food they are taken
from their families many times and there
is nothing more valuable than the love
of a mother and of a family this is what
we should have in our focus in the
European Union and the member states I
have uh dealt with cases of children
which were taken from families and which
were recovered after three or four years
who were traumatized why were they taken
away for alleged reasons that maybe
family was too poor but let us intervene
here let us ensure um sustenance for the
family let us ensure jobs for parents so
that these children can grow in families
and not in state institutions thank you
next speaker colleague Mr Andrews def
Flor is yours
please thank you madam president
commissioner and colleagues on world
children's day I want to focus on two
issues firstly foster care is part of
the European child guarantee and it is
of course a recommended intervention for
the most vulnerable uh children
preferred over Residential Care however
foster care is delivered in a very
incoherent way across member states
there are no common standards for the
delivery of foster care or for training
of foster parents we recently adopted a
position on aspects of crossb adoption
and we should do the same regarding
foster care and the Brussels convention
in particular secondly as Minister for
children in Ireland I introduced the
scheme that delivered Early Childhood
care and education the intention was
that this would lead to the increased
professionalization of workers in this
sector so that they could diagnose early
developmental delays in children and
design appropriate interventions and I
hope that that's where it goes finally
it is impossible on world children day
not to repeat what the wh's Dr Mike said
the best medicine for the children of
Gaza is a ceasefire thank
you thank you next speaker Mr Wallace
the floor is yours thanks very much
president the convention on the rights
of the child was adopted on this day in
1989 by the UN the US still hasn't
signed it Israel has killed over 5,000
children in the last 6 weeks thanks to
the support of the US and EU American
journalist Chris Hedges was in an alzer
Studio watching a live fet from G Gaza
City of Israel attacking alifa Hospital
a deliberate attack on a on the hospital
he said a deliberate War crime a
deliberate Massacre of the most helpless
civilians including infants then the
feed goes dead we know what this means
he said no power no water no internet no
medical supplies every infant in an
incubator will die everyone who needs
emergency surgery will die let there be
no doubt if Israel the US and EU are
sending a chilling message to the rest
of the world international and
humanitarian law the convention on the
rights of the child are meaningless
pieces of paper they did not apply in
Iraq or Afghanistan and they don't apply
in Gaza they don't hate us for our
values maybe they hate us because we
don't have
[Music]
any next speaker uh colleague Mrs
kinichi the floor is yours
please
thank you thank you president
commissioner according to a report
published last September by
eurostat we are going to have almost 20
million children below the age of 18 at
risk of poverty or social
exclusion as is always the case in
crisis situations such as the covid-19
pandemic and the war in Ukraine the
highest prices paid by the
children amongst these once again it is
the most vulnerable who are those most
affected children from migrant
backgrounds refugees unaccompanied
minors but also children who come from
single parent families children with
disabilities and um children who are
part of an ethnic
minority this is a fundamental
instrument to help us to combat child
poverty for millions of children in
Europe and it needs to be strengthened
we now need the member states to imp
Implement effective National plans so
that every child in Europe can have a
real guarantee of a healthy and safe
childhood as the UN convention would
have it thank you thank you very much
next speaker colleague Mrs Dy the floor
is
yes thank you president it's World
Children's Day the day when we
commemorate the signing of the UN
convention on the rights of the child
the most widely ratified human rights
treaty ever the world United around the
protection of children well aren't we
great and it's about time that we wake
up and smell the white phosphorus the
burning flesh of children torched alive
in Gaza wake up and hear their screams
over the dead bodies of their parents
their severed limbs their blinded eyes
their parched lips their starving
stomachs feel their Terror day after day
after day after day
as the bombs run down on their homes
their schools their
hospitals on and on it goes and all the
great Nations that signed this great
treaty to protect children sit on their
hands and we Pat ourselves on the back
in places like this while not just doing
nothing but enabling that Israeli
genocide against children to continue
well the people of the world have seen
through your complicity if you mean a
of concern for children stop the
slaughter demand the
ceasefire thank you and now I would like
to give the floor again to vice
president commissioner Madame scht the
floor is
yours thank you very much chair
honorable members once again we thank
you for your support for the European
child guarantee we take note of your
calls for for strong governance and
adequate uh funding there were several
questions I will try to reply few of
them Madame yarus and Mr Andrew asked
about U how to further invest in
children so we agree that we have to
further invest in Early Child Education
and Care and in the meals for children
in schools it was already done with the
ESF ESF plus but I have to tell you
member states should do more Madame
Nicholson she's not here anymore on Roma
children they have been direct
beneficiaries of the pilot projects
under the child guarantee Preparatory
action in Croatia and Bulgaria and
commissioner Schmidt and me visited one
such site and witnessed this on the
ground but again we need
more once again I must draw attention to
the fact that primary responsibility for
the implementation of the child
guarantee lies with member
states uh if you remember at the PTO
Summit we have committed that to lift at
least 5 million children out of poverty
by
2030 and we are still far from
that I agree with you that more decisive
actions are needed to move into this
direction and to reverse these negative
Trends we are committed to continue
working with the European Parliament on
advising advancing the fight against
poverty and we will closely follow up on
your report the World of Tomorrow all of
us know is likely to be very different
from the world we know today the green
and digital transitions require that
today's children are well equipped and
they that they have equal opportunities
to thrive in the years to come
demographic change our third transition
is bringing challenges and opportunities
for all
generations and as all of us know our
societies will become longevity
societies 50% of children who are born
now may reach the age 90 or 95 cycles of
poverty and disadvantage start early on
and will impact our lives and and
societies through throughout the entire
life cycle we therefore need to ensure
an equal start in life for present and
future Generations in an inclusive
Society where each voice is heard this
is why we are putting so much emphasis
on child participation in
policym as all of us know and we would
agree children are part of the
solution the Universal Protection of
children's rights in an increasingly
reality on the
ground yes what is hardly won can be
easily lost our Collective work will
only be done when we have successfully
put an end to an to end uh child poverty
and social inclusion for all children we
need to ensure and we we need to make
sure that intergenerational solidarity
and fairness becomes a reality of our
everyday work that children can enjoy
the rights they have now and their
rights as future Generations my
colleague commission Schmid and I look
forward to continuing continuing work
with you uh on this file and I hope that
we can move the uh World on in this and
I want to thank you once again for this
interest in this on the international
day uh on the International Day of
children rights of children thank
you and we thank you uh Madame
commissioner last but not least let me
give the floor again to our reporter
Madame Pereira
please
thank you very much our responsibility
as ever is to call on institutions and
governments to make
sure that they always push to go further
to
integrate children's rights because
after all children will transform the
world we know that governments
promises need to be translated into
action and we need to make sure we're
taking that those extra steps to make
sure that children and their
families are always front and
center of
our
designs we have to make sure that the
member states have that capacity to
carry on investing in children's Futures
and make sure that people who are at
risk of poverty those who are most
vulnerable are
protected uh we see these sort of things
happening in in my country in Portugal
as well making sure that you see school
we're seeing schools without um teachers
for certain subjects we're seeing a lack
of crush places we're seeing
privatization and National governments
and the commission complicit in these
sort of policies we need a different
policy different set of policies to help
children be children to allow them to
dream and grow up
happily
so thank you to everybody thank you to
the Shadow rapporter and their
assistants thank you to the emple
Secretariat and thank you to my team as
well Lu Fu and
Sophia and we thank you uh Madame
reporter uh I have received one motion
for resolution to wind up this debates
The Joint debate is closed and the vote
will be held tomorrow thank you very
much Madame commissioner we now move on
to the next item on the agenda which is
commission statement un climate change
confence